So I'm going to give you the solution
for this particular question by filling out this
table. And as I said, take your time thinking about it. And, and verifying your
own intuition against what I'm presenting to
you here. Now what you'll find is that
MCS Link-based queue lock and Anderson's array-based
queue lock are the two things, two algorithms
that done, do quite well on most of
the different categories of attributes that I have mentioned
to you. But I should tell you that if
you, if you have fancy instructions. Fancy read, modify,
write instructions. Then Anderson's and MCS lock give
you the best performance on all these attributes. But
on the other hand, if the architecture does not
support fancy read modified op operations and it only
has testing set operation available, then some sort of a, a delay base, is a,
in a exponential delay base or. Starting
delay based, spin lock algorithm, may turn out
to be the best performer. And in fact, when the amount of contention for lock
is, is, fairly low, it's best to use
a spin lock with exponential delay, start out
a small delay and keep increasing it. On the other
hand, if it is a highly contended lock Then it is
good to use a Spin Lock that has categorically assigned various
spots for every processor. And one of the things that I
also want you to notice is that the number of
re modify right operations that, you need to do for the
different lock algorithms really depends on the amount of contention that
is there for the lock in the case of spin algorithms.
In the case of Anderson's and MCS the number of
Atomic operation is always one, regardless of how much contention
there is. And of course, in MCS, this is the
quanta keys that you have to worry about during, during
unlocking that might result in an extra remodified item operation.
But in the case of the Spin algorithms the amount
of contention is really dependent on the number of re
modified item operations that you have to perform per critical section.
Really depends on the, mode of, mode of contention that is there for the lock.